this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
non-minimalists
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists today we're going to
talk about
raising organized children and of course
there's a
a book of roughly the same title
and we have dr damon corp here to
discuss it so um
doc i figured we would uh we would start
by just
in your book you say organ organized
children are not born they are raised
um what do you mean by this well we're
we're born with a certain capacity
but that capacity depending on how we
teach and we educate our kids
it changes greatly starting when kids
are infants
all the way through adolescence we keep
growing and developing what we call our
executive functions especially
right that's what we're talking about
with organization is our executive
functions
okay okay so um well i'm
i'm a little ignorant here uh can you
expand on executive functions a little
bit what does what does that mean
absolutely in my world it's a popular
term but i understand that walking down
the street we don't talk about that very
much
so it's it's our ability to organize
space it's our ability to organize time
it's our ability but even more important
than that to shift flexibly from one
thought to the next
to be able to control our impulses
demonstrate self-control okay and then
one more function called working memory
which i think is the key to all of that
that's the ability to do more than one
thing in your brain at a time which is
important for
grasping the big picture showing insight
taking perspective
all those things that we need to do as
our young people grow into
adults okay awesome talk to you about
behavioral
pediatrics so this is what you do
for your day job so to speak but what
does that even mean
so i'm a developmental behavioral
pediatrician which means i went to
medical school and then i
did my pediatric residency and then just
like a pediatric cardiologist would
i became a pediatric developmental
behavioral
pediatrician so i did a couple year
fellowship in child behavior and
development and we look at how kids
learn and how kids behave and
and uh how the brain grows when you talk
about organized
children what do you mean by this
because when i say organized sometimes i
really think of organization as
well planned hoarding because i remember
back in my 20s i was a very well
organized hoarder and so i had boxes and
bins
that this isn't what you mean by
organization so maybe you can you can
clarify
yeah that's a good point i'm i'm talking
about organized thinking
yeah so it's not just a neat room or
finding two socks that match
it's about being able to grasp the big
picture it's about being able to solve
your own problems and to be able to plan
so it's been rough for kids recently uh
i hear 2020 was a difficult year
and uh now we're in 2021 and it's a bit
of a sequel
and whether it is and with my own
daughter um
you know the shutdowns online school
canceled extracurricular activities and
sports
and various iterations depending on your
geography
the it's been a weird weird world for
kids now i do find that kids
often adapt better than we do is that
is that a fair assessment but also they
may struggle in other areas more than we
do
that's a big question the the uh there's
a lot of layers to this and it really
depends on the child
on the average kids are sleeping more
which is cool
yeah uh on the average kids report that
they're closer to their parents than
they were
uh before the pandemic which is
interesting
and so there are some things about it
that are nice silver linings
at the same time kids with mental health
issues kids with autism
kids who have had pre-existing
conditions learning disabilities are
really struggling with online school
so for some kids those who already had a
disadvantage
i think are being even disadvantaged
more by the pandemic
right right and i've just noticed uh a
certain amount of
and i think part of this has just do
with proximity you're not used to being
around your kids
this much and so what i've noticed uh
even in my own life is is
trying to set up my own boundaries
while in a boundary-less space so to
speak can we talk a bit about boundaries
with our kids
well i think it's a good opportunity to
talk about getting back to the basics
right the basics and this is what i
write about in my book there's five
steps
and the first one is be consistent the
second is introduce order third is give
everything a place
fourth is practice forward thinking like
estimating anticipating planning
and the fifth is problem solving promote
problem solving but if we're at the very
basic
be consistent well that's what
boundaries are about it's about be
consistent here's the rules here's the
bed times here's the schedule here's the
routine
and kids find security in having that
type of
boundary placed upon them yes yes indeed
well ours is a listener driven show i
thought we would dive into some
questions here our first one
is a phone call from josh in phoenix
arizona
how do you think minimalism can reach
people
at a younger age so they don't find out
when they're older
and it's a lot more stressful to go
through
so damon let's talk about this uh
we're talking about adopting he's
talking about minimalist practices but
any sort of habit or whatever it goes
beyond the sort of the basics of
of behavior change or habit change
that's obviously
a byproduct of something but i think a
lot of that has to do with
with understanding and maybe if i were
to rephrase the question
josh's question here i would say how do
we help our children
adopt practices that stick at an early
age so they don't lose
so they don't lose those those habits
right and
suffer consequences in adulthood i know
a lot of my adulthood suffering has to
do with the
decisions that were made 30 years ago or
longer right
i am when you all called me at first i
was like
that's an interesting fit why are they
calling a doctor and and the more i
listen to your show
um talking about minimalism it makes me
think about minimalism parenting how do
you be a minimalistic parent
and i think that's very different than
what's going on in our culture today we
all feel the need to get them in the
best school and get them on the most
competitive sport team even if our kid's
not very athletic we want them on the
most
competitive sport team and and in doing
that that pressure that push that that
schedule the over schedule the lack of
sleep all that stuff adds up
sends a message to your kids and i think
as a parent if you're going to start at
the basic you start with
what are the most important things for
my child to be involved in what are the
lessons i think are important for them
to learn
but also what are they interested in and
how can i help them
find their greatness yeah i feel like
with this question specifically uh
targeted at minimalism i don't think you
can
tell a kid how to be a minimalist i
think as a parent
maybe you show a kid how to be a
minimalist i mean
kids don't uh what does joshua becker
say kids don't do what we say they do
what we do
so uh yeah when it comes to these things
uh we can
um certainly tell our kids until our you
know faces are red but really we
i feel like as a parent you know i say
we i have no kids
but i really feel like as a parent you
have to lead by example and that's kind
of the best way
to instill these practices early on
would you agree with that
absolutely we constantly ask our kids is
this important do you think we should
is it worth our effort is it worth our
time my daughter's
uh 15 my youngest daughter i have five
kids which gives me some
cred when we're talking about this but
not the minimalist there
minimalist um we but she's 15 and she
constantly wants to be involved
she feels like she needs to be involved
in these things to to
get into college to get into the college
she wants to get into or she thinks she
wants to get into
sure but but the reality is if you find
something you like
you get good at it you share it with
your community colleges are going to
want you
yeah it's interesting so she knows which
college she wants to go to
is that um like how did she get there
how did she come to that decision was
that you
saying hey you need to go to this
college i'm sure it wasn't that uh damon
but how did she get there to make that
decision how did you help her get there
yeah i'm not sure she's down to one
college i think originally her
her dream was duke because when we
toured colleges with my
oldest son 10 years older than her they
had fountains that sprayed up by the
cafeteria that she liked
so that was that was what she wanted um
and it's stuck in the back of her head
but now i think she just is thinking i
would like to go to it i need to get
into a good
college gotcha gotcha yeah so so when
you go through decision-making process
with your kids and we're talking about
habits it's i
to me it doesn't it's never about you
know i'm thinking about ella here
i don't think i've ever tried to instill
a particular habit for the sake of
giving her a habit
right i think a lot more it has a lot
more to do with
decision making and maybe helping
helping her make informed decisions and
how do we do that i think it's through
asking questions and gathering
information
right so that's when i'm talking about
the five steps that's step five is how
do you teach your kid to be a problem
solver
and part of that is you give them the
opportunity to solve their own problems
yes yeah the biggest problem i think
kids
are rescued from by their parents these
days is boredom we don't let our kids be
bored anymore
boredom is a good thing because it's
ever present problems you're constantly
practicing and rehearsing
and and getting better on how to solve
that but if you give them a phone every
time you have 15 minute wait at the
restaurant
they're not having to solve that problem
anymore yeah and so their creativity is
diminished and their problem-solving
skills are weakened
that's a great point i feel like in this
day and age like being comfortable with
boredom is almost like a superpower at
this point because there's so many
distractions yeah that's a great point
ella will sometimes
say to me i'm bored i'm bored and and
i know what i say to that and i'll i'll
talk about it but i'd be interested to
hear what you say
to that or do about that so it depends
on the child's
skill level sure um one of the things
and we can talk about this later about
in the book is you have to know your
child's skill level
but in general to my kids i'd say great
what are you going to do about it
okay that would be my answer is great
how are you going to solve it what could
you do
now if their skill level was lower i
might um
have made plans with them what are
things you could do on a rainy day and
we'd have a list
what are things that you could do when
nobody is available to play with you
what could you do when your friends come
over
and and we'd have these lists i said why
don't you go check out one of your lists
that way i'm not telling them what to do
but they can go to at least to a little
bit of a
guideline i don't know where to start
wow so like you have them planned in
advance
that's great that's a great idea wow
when i talk about understanding
it different from the sort of how to
side of things because the how to would
be well here's
i'm handing you the list of five things
to do or here's the one thing
very dictatorial and i know as parents
uh i don't know if you've struggled with
this but in the past
up until very recently very very
recently i struggled with
um with giving the answer and and being
the sort of
dictator not allowing the room for
exploration
and and part of that was egoic in a way
was like
well i know better than you and in some
instances i do that's why
boundaries are necessary but i think it
i think quite often
she knows better than i do and maybe
part of my job is to learn something
from her along the way
so it is great to watch your own
children but you know i think the other
reason we do it is we we just want to
help our kids right we just want them to
to be happy and in that moment they seem
distressed
and distress isn't necessarily a bad
thing a little bit of distress kind of
drives ingenuity
and if we take it away from them they
lose that opportunity to solve
problems for themselves but we want to
rescue them so we say well
go play with your brother and why don't
you go outside here's this you can watch
a show
and we save them from that that distress
yeah but it's creating future distress
in a way right because it's not giving
them the skill set
that is actually it's not going to give
them the understanding that gives them
the skill set to be able to handle on
their own the future
instead it creates a a person who needs
to show up and get permission or or
direction every single time you know
what you just touched on
is um what i see is one of the greatest
similarities between the way you all
think and the way i do is that
parenting is work yeah minimalism is
work it's effort up front
but it gets easier and makes life more
simple as you go on
right so if you set your boundaries and
set your rules when they're little it
gets much easier if you train your child
to sleep when they're an infant
it's much easier than if you're training
them to sleep when they're five or six
or seven and can come into your bedroom
yeah yeah well so so many of us get to
that point where we realize
like especially i'm sure you you
recognize this by having multiple
children and each time you've it's
almost like that that first kid was a
the quite the test experiment right and
yeah i knew very little
and and of course if i could go back and
redo
the first seven years there are so many
things i would do differently
having the knowledge i have now that's
not possible so now at
age seven ella will be eight relatively
soon
um i do feel i i feel that constant tug
that i have to let go of that tug of
like
oh i wish i would have done this
differently i wish i would have done
that differently but in doing so staying
attached to that
means that i'm not doing the things
differently that i need to do
right now sort of the whole the whole
buddhist philosophy of beginning again
yeah
now is the only time i can begin again i
can't go back and and change that
i think that's why like grandparents are
so good to grandkids
because they're like it's an opportunity
to kind of redo what they did with their
with their kids that's a wonderful point
i um
uh first of all my kids will watch this
so don't let my first son know that he's
the experiment
but but but secondly i've coached a lot
of sports i've coached 20 seasons of
youth sports and
and i can tell who's a first-time parent
and who's not a first-time parent if the
first time parents child gets injured in
a game
they're on the court immediately if it's
a second or third time parent they know
the kid's going to get up and it's going
to be
okay if it's a first-time parent they're
worried that their child's not getting
enough play time
the second or third time parent kind of
knows they got to earn their play time
and they've gotta they've gotta it's
gotta work out so
yeah there's a relaxation a calmness
that happens
but i guess the advice i would give to
those first-time parents is gosh
people's
people have been having babies for a
long time yeah
and and they grow up into adults and for
the most part
they're okay yeah yeah if you and i
turned out okay ryan
that that's always the thing with ella
where i'm like
oh like there's nothing go even there's
not going to be any of the turmoil or
just a fraction of the turmoil that we
experienced growing up
then and somehow we we made it out of
that yeah
i totally agree with that you were
talking earlier about um letting your
kids sit with boredom and not doing
everything for them or constantly
keeping them stimulated
and it made me think about like i know
people who
had their parents do everything for them
cleaning the room
buying them whatever they you know
wanted to get you know ra you know for
all intents purposes raising a spoiled
brat
and uh that person as an adult
it's very hard for them to function
because they kind of were used to
everything being
done for them now josh and i had the
exact opposite where
we um really didn't have a lot we didn't
have our parents uh really being good
parents to us
but in a way like it did it helped us
become good people so i often ask myself
like when
mariah my wife and i when we uh finally
have a kid
it's like how do i how do i put them
through just enough turmoil
to like make them you know uh become a
good adult so i know there's a balance
there somewhere but i think that's what
all parents are probably asking
themselves like where is that balance of
doing too much and doing too little
and especially with those first-time
parents who are worried about
you know uh being a really bad parent i
mean there's a lot going on there
not not just good people but
self-confident you know that if there's
an obstacle you can handle it because
you handled obstacles in the past
and if we do that for our kids we handle
all their obstacles
then when it's time for them to launch
into the world they
struggle so i'll give you another i talk
about my kids all the time because
they're great
um but a little victory my daughter has
a little medical issue she's dealing
with right now she got an abnormal lab
back
and he's feeling crummy and told the
doctor they said i need you to get
another lab she called all the labs and
where she is
and uh they they told her um that
there's
nothing available for two weeks no
appointments and she's feeling pretty
crummy
and she said dad i'm gonna handle it i'm
gonna go to the lab show up i'm going to
stand there and i'm just going to beg
them till they let me in
and she called me up a couple hours
later she said yep they turned away
three people but they let me in dad
that's awesome oh wow that's a victory
right yes solving problems 20 years old
great way to go right and the problem
solving from that doesn't come from
a a list of well here are the seven
steps you need to take in order to
to um get the the blood because if you
just follow those steps then it's okay
step three is wait was wait two weeks
apparently right
and so but when you are presented with a
problem and you
truly understand the the the problem the
essence of the problem
then you figure out the the way around
it and that that sort of problem solving
that maneuvering because
there were probably 18 other ways that
she could have solved it and got the
same result
but it doesn't matter that it it's she
found the path that worked for her
right and i didn't get on the phone and
say i'm dr core but i need you to get my
daughter in
yeah sound like a complete jerk let them
roll their eyes on the other end of the
phone and say i'm sorry sir we're busy
she solved it herself yes yeah and i
think that's so important well josh
josh in phoenix i'm going to send you a
copy of dr korb's
book ryan what time is it you know what
time it is it is time for our lightning
round where we answer your text messages
you can text
your comments and questions to area code
937-202-4654 yes indeed now during the
lightning round
doc here's what we do we answer
questions with a short shareable less
than 140 character response
but not really what we do is we ramble
on a bit and we we just talk about the
question and
eventually we tweeze out something that
is pithy that podcast sean puts in the
show notes so we
can copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you're listening to this
and you want to share something
nicole has a question for us ryan how do
you balance setting boundaries with a
child
and allowing them room to explore and
learn about who they are
you know i think this is fascinating
damon because
the this is the the obviously we've
needed boundaries
for millennia right even pre-agriculture
we were living in caves there were
boundaries so we didn't get eaten by
a apex predator right so even then
parents needed
bound to set up boundaries i think the
difference now is quite often
we set up these sort of arbitrary
boundaries that are
in a way harmful to our children is that
fair
yeah we send mixed messages and we we
don't let them explore
i mean when you're starting with
boundaries you start with safety right
you can't touch the hot stove
you know the one or two-year-old you
can't touch the hot stove you can't
touch the electrical outlets
you're gonna hold my hand when we're
near the street those kind of boundaries
but you can let them explore and let
them ramble i always say
never lift a child into a tree but if
they can climb it they can climb as high
as they want because they can get down
if they can climb it
and so you have your boundaries um but
but also let them operate within their
strengths abilities and
own personal limitations yeah yeah but
there was something pithy for you sean
to put in the show it's about the tree
climbing
that's solid yeah that's great i got
something pithy for you here our desire
to control
impedes our ability to love so
i think quite often i feel as though i
want to
control ella right it and because it's
there's a certain righteousness in me
when i do it as well
and if i'm completely honest
there is a wow
there's a disdain for her behavior
and and that disdain is is really a
mirror reflecting
my own disdain for parenting lack of
parenting my
own flaws etc so i think whenever i
whenever i try to control someone
especially
my child it it often impedes my ability
to
to love them to be loving and um
i think sometimes we confuse things that
feel loving
with the act of loving it might feel
loving in that moment to styrofoam
or to bubble wrap everything to keep her
safe but that's not an act of love
that's act of fear i'm going to take the
next 90 minutes to answer that question
because
there are so many levels there the the
first level
is it has to do with your expectations
yes
i expect a certain outcome and if it
doesn't go that way
then i'm disappointed that's your own
personal issues your own baggage you got
to deal with that
but you have to make sure your
expectations are realistic so
if you have a five-year-old and you're
wondering how i can get them to want to
clean their room
that's not realistic five-year-olds
don't want to clean their room they
might
learn how to clean their room or they
might learn that they have to clean
their room but they're not going to want
to and if that's your expectation
you're going to constantly be
disappointed in your child which is
really disappointed in your own
expectation
the second thing to know is you know we
talked about boundaries
and um if you ever rode a roller coaster
and i'm sure you have
the first thing you do when you get into
a roller coaster is you pull that safety
bar down oh yeah
and the next thing you do everybody
shakes it right you shake it because you
want to make sure it's going to be there
when you need it
right that's what your kids are going to
do they're going to shake you you're
going to put your rule
and they're going to shake you and you
can't take that personally that's what
they're supposed to do
they're supposed to test whether or not
it's a real
thing that's going on here so so that's
that's really important to know that
they're going to
test you and i guess the third
point to emphasize is you know sting
says if you love someone you gotta let
them go right
um as your kids get older you have to
give them more freedom
to be who they are they have to find
their friends and figure out what their
passions and interests are and it may
not be yours
and so i talk to teens all the time and
i say to them
you've got to help your parents let go
you have to let them know that you're
safe
by letting them know that you'll be a
home at a certain time and then come
home at a certain time
that's how you're preparing them for you
going off to college and becoming an
adult
because parenting is traumatizing
parenting is is absolutely traumatized i
mean in the middle of the night
we're up two in the morning holding our
child who who's
diarrheaed all over us and and and
thrown up on us and doing all this it's
traumatizing
so the by the time you have a teenager
we all have
parenting ptsd a little bit yeah and and
the way you deal with somebody with ptsd
is you give them assurances and not just
tell them but you show them
over and over it's going to be okay and
that's what i need teens to learn to do
to their parents
is to show us that it's going to be okay
so when it's time to let go
we as parents are able to do that it's a
two-way street
it's really great advice for parents
with teenagers because
you know it seems like the parents are
always setting the boundaries
but asking the teenagers to do that um
it's not a huge ask and uh yeah it
creates a great relationship with their
parents
that's great advice um my pithy answer
is this
we often don't discover our boundaries
until they've been crossed
so what i mean by that is there are the
obvious boundaries
that parents can set don't touch the hot
stove hold my hand as we're crossing the
street look both ways wear your seat
belt there are these obvious boundaries
but then there are some boundaries that
aren't so obvious like you know when is
the appropriate curfew
um when is the appropriate day age to
start dating
i mean there are there are these things
uh that i feel like
and again not having kids it's so easy
to give parenting advice so you tell me
damon how
if i'm way off base here but i feel like
as a parent you have to be willing to
let your kids
fail a little bit so what i mean by that
is i grew up like my dad was a very
strict christian father
so i had these boundaries that i was
constantly
crossing that he had set because they
were a little bit too extreme
my mom was on the other side where she
gave me no boundaries so i had to kind
of discover you know what my boundaries
were with her
um but yeah what do you think about that
as far as like how
what can we tell parents to help them
maybe be okay with like
letting their kids fail a little bit and
discovering those boundaries on their
own
so you know there is no perfect
parenting book because
every child is different you mean your
book isn't the perfect parenting book
it's really close in fact
what i try to do is i i try to talk in
terms of concepts
parenting concepts these are the big
picture things because to apply it to
individual children if i say
this is the best way to do this it
really depends on your child
on their temperament and their
experiences
because you're right every boundary can
be crossed in a different way and you
can't predict and anticipate
every single way right so so yeah it
really depends on
on the way your child is going to turn
and then you fall back on the basics
you know what's the big picture here why
am i upset
and fall back on that because if you can
model big picture thinking when you're
dealing with
that's it i'm taking away your phone for
the next three weeks well you know just
because they swore at me is that really
worth taking away their phone or through
maybe they swore at me because they're
really mad at me and maybe there's a
reason for them to be mad you know you
have to step back and see the big
picture
um but yeah they'll cross boundaries you
never even knew existed
yeah right now now is it true though
that we also we set up
boundaries that don't need to exist and
that can be
as big of a problem as not setting up
boundaries right
but by being too rigid in our thinking
and as you said
so eloquently i in fact sean another
pithy answer for you was about
when you're disappointed your kid you're
disappointed your own expectations right
and um that has to do with setting up
i'm not gonna say the wrong boundaries
but inappropriate boundaries
yeah don't chew with your mouth open
when you're two well don't don't get
don't get dirty when you're five right i
mean they're supposed to get dirty
um and so yeah we have to really think
about what's
what's the purpose of our boundary and
why are we setting limits here i
i tell when i talk to parent groups one
of the things i say is is there's
uh 5hs that kids have to do teens have
to do and if they're doing that
you got a pretty good kid and you're
going to be okay and that's take care of
your health
which is exercise sleep nutrition take
care of your hygiene
shower brush your teeth put on deodorant
take care of your homework
do your household chores and then hang
out
with your friends and if you're doing
those five things you're learning the
lessons
that you need in order to be successful
not you know why i've picked those is
because
none of those things really help kids in
the immediate uh
in the immediate doing your homework
that's not gonna help me now it's gonna
help me years down the road right
um wearing deodorant i can't smell my
own stink i don't know that i think it's
because i know
that i may show up somewhere and
somebody else may smell my stink
that's why i put on deodorant so you've
got a forward thinking kid if they can
do those five things
yeah so if all these other boundaries
and all these other rules
that room has to be perfectly clean no
it has to be clean when grandma's coming
over
it doesn't have to be clean all the time
yeah yeah that's dialing back your
expectations
not just in a reasonable way but but in
a way that's not going to drive you
crazy as a parent
absolutely and that's minimalism right
yeah that's right
maybe a question to go along with
nicole's here is you know not just how
do you set these boundaries up but like
having a plan for dealing for when these
boundaries are crossed like i think
about
um a couple friends of mine who were
parents and they have a teenage son who
has crossed some boundaries and
certainly there are repercussions
and they have those uh you know those
those punishments or whatever it is that
that uh they gave to him but they also
really sat with him and was like well
how did it how did it make you feel that
you crossed this boundary
and he you know he had to work with uh
you know kind of
gaining his parents trust back and like
they worked together
to figure out a way like okay like i
understand
that you broke our trust let's talk
about how we can get that back and uh
really helping him learn from crossing
that boundary i think is uh
that's something that i want to do when
i'm a parent easier said than done i'm
sure
absolutely because you want to react
immediately right your your pride has
been hurt
when somebody when somebody when your
child doesn't do what you tell them to
do and so you want to react but yeah
stepping back in fact that's what
therapy is a lot of therapy
when families go to therapy is well what
did you do and why did you do that and
why did you feel that way
yeah and you know what could you do next
time and and the more you do that you
kind of get this
pocket of uh options that you can you
can pull out
when your child is struggling or making
a difficult choice
yeah all right before we get into our
listener comments and our added value
segment today it looks like we got a
bunch more surprise questions this week
like
how do you support a child if they rebel
against everything they've been taught
how do you deliver difficult news to
young children how can we as parents
help messy kids
be less messy how can i help my child
manage their anger and sad emotions
plus tips for raising an independent
child and a million more questions for
dr corb
and the minimalists and if you want to
hear all that listen to the minimalist
private podcast this week visit
theminimalists.com
support to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our private
podcast plays
in your favorite podcast app plus
private podcast subscribers gain access
to hundreds of hours of private archives
it's cheaper than a cup of coffee and it
keeps our show 100 percent
advertisement free ryan what else you
got for us this week here are some
voicemail comments
and insights from our listeners check
them out hi this is marissa from south
bend indiana i recently had a packing
party for my iphone
i removed all my apps from the home
screen which is different than deleting
them
this means they will just be on the last
page and you have to search for it by
name to bring it up
then for two weeks when i needed an app
i would add it back to my home screen
after the two weeks were done i deleted
all the apps i didn't use anymore
hi josh and ryan this is jennifer in
rochester new york
i have two short comments one is to
katrina
who was on podcast 43 she had a question
about the wedding gift
i just wanted to remind everybody that
instead of asking for experience gifts
or not asking for gifts you can also ask
for donations to your
favorite charity my cousin did this at
her wedding and it was wonderful
you could leave a donation and you could
leave your name along with the donation
so they would know
that you gifted to them concerning
your podcast with rich roll i wanted to
remind everyone about the grocery store
aldi if it is in your city
please check it out they're having a
larger and larger assortment of organic
foods they have grass-fed beef you can
purchase and it's very affordable
all right thank you so much to dr damon
korb for joining us today check out his
book it's called raising
an organized child you can follow him on
social media he's just
at dr core we'll also put a link to his
website
in the show notes he by the way he has a
new course coming out
about organized students so if you
follow him on social media at dr
corb you'll be able to get updates about
that as soon as it's available
and uh for added value segment this week
ryan i wanted to talk about
since i thought this was appropriate to
talking about parenting and sometimes i
feel
powerless as a parent you know what i'm
saying
you really make parenting not sound fun
yeah yeah but what does rob bell say
that that uh
your number one job as a parent is to
enjoy your kids and your number one job
is to not kill your kid
anyway i do at times feel powerless so
our friend matt carney has a new album
coming out he actually
i don't know if you know this i did a
quarantine conversation with him over on
patreon yeah
and we were the first place that he
announced the name of his new album he
just announced it publicly
but privately on our private podcast he
uh matt carney talked about
the name for his new album which is
called january flower
it comes out in may but he just put out
a new song called
powerless it's the the first song on the
album so let's
wrap up this episode with that song at
the end powerless
by matt carney from his forthcoming
album
january flower and real quick for right
here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalist a lot of you have
been asking about
behind the scenes from our new film less
is now which is available on netflix
and we have a bunch of footage but matt
did a really great job matthew vela our
director
he on his youtube channel he made a
video called how i got
my film on netflix you would not believe
how many people will get a hold of me i
have a documentary can you help me get
on netflix
oh here's the video for it yeah this is
this is beautiful
and what he does he actually talks about
how we got turned down by netflix
several times with our first film
until and and the alternate routes that
we took and eventually it ended up on
netflix how it got there
but he also shares a lot of the process
of making the new film
and the tremendous failures that we went
through
over a four-year period you know we
thought it was going to take four months
it ended up taking four years to make
this film
and you get to see some of the aspects
that we recorded in in fact some deleted
scenes ryan had
this overdose scene and you get to see
parts of that
and so let's just put a link to that
sean if we put a link to that in the
show notes
it's called how i got my film on netflix
it's on matiavella's youtube
channel but it includes a whole bunch of
behind the scenes
from les is now you can follow the
minimalists on
facebook twitter and instagram at the
minimalist come to one of our live
podcast shows visit theminimalists.com
tour to find a city near you if you have
a question comment or minimalism tip for
our podcast
email a voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com
comment on this episode youtube.com
slash the minimalist and if you want our
show notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list over at
theminimalists.com you'll also receive
our simple
sunday emails and if you leave here
today with just
one message let it be this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'd be fine
without it